bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 votre
rendez vous quotidien avec l'information
locale sur tv fil 78 heures en direct 18
19 heures pour faire le point complet
bon sens valérie puisque nous sommes le
mardi nous allons parler environnement
comme chaque semaine avec vous
absolument et puisque nous venons de
traverser une période de grand froid
nous allons voir comment est gérée le
réseau d'électricité à montigny le
bretonneux avec nous inviter tout à
l'heure en plateau
ce sera la chronique de l'environnement
au cours de la seconde partie de cette
édition l'information du jour c'est
cette mobilisation des salariés de
renault toujours en colère contre les
suppressions de postes à venir le
délégué syndical cgt du technocentre à
guyancourt mathieu golinelli est avec
nous bonsoir nous entendrons dans un
instant ce sera juste après les titres
les sujets qui seront développés au
cours de cette heure d'émission ce 29
janvier je vous le disais la
mobilisation d'une partie des salariés
de renault opérations des débrayages sur
différents sites avec lui en cours une
heure de grève a été observée ce matin
et à flins 500 salariés rassemblés pour
dire non au plan de compétitivité
société vous cherchez un baby sitter et
vous avez du mal à en trouver pour vous
épauler une ville du département
montigny le bretonneux a lancé un baby
site dating entre étudiants et parents
et c'était un franc succès de l'ombre à
la lumière d'un salon de coiffure aux
plateaux de télévision c'est l'aventuré
menée par emilie tesnière coiffeuse elle
est aussi de montigny le bretonneux elle
officie sur les plateaux de la star
academy et doit-on aimé tout le monde
c'est la question posée à des enfants de
7 à 11 ans à l'occasion d'un atelier
philo proposé à magny les hameaux
l'atelier se déroule une fois par mois
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que les enfants ont des choses à
raconter à noter que je recevrai aussi
ce soir le président de la fédération
française du bâtiment dans le
département des yvelines daniel
taravella et les est agacé actuellement
du silence des politiques face à leurs
préoccupations et puis la rédaction
reviendra bien évidemment sur les
différentes cérémonies
de voeux des maires aux personnalités ce
soir jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt il a organisé sa cérémonie
de voeux vendredi dernier un nouveau
rendez-vous aujourd'hui avec les
syndicats ce 29 janvier pour les groupes
automobiles français renault psa peugeot
citroën sur fond de tension sociale et
de débrayages et psa située dans les
yvelines à vélizy pour la conception à
poissy également pour l'assemblage on a
d'ailleurs appris aujourd'hui que la
justice a ordonné la suspension du plan
de restructuration qui concerne plus de
8000 postes en france c'est un premier
sursis concernant renault je reçois donc
ce soir mathieu golinelli
donc bon soir avoue délégué syndical cgt
technocentre à guyancourt
tout d'abord votre réaction peut-être
sur la situation du côté de psa avec
cette décision de justice est ce sursis
en quelque sorte accordé avec cette
suspension du plan de restructuration
vous espérez la même chose
éventuellement pour renault on imagine
nous espérons évidemment la même chose
pour renault pour le maintien des
emplois dans les usines et en france
vous avez été surpris satisfait comment
vous avez accueilli cette décision de 2
ps 1 là je le découvre là on dirait que
c'est la façon que je vous donne donc
aujourd'hui effectivement vous nous le
dites vous aimeriez bien la même chose
du côté de renault on va comprendre
pourquoi dans quelques instants
aujourd'hui il y avait des discussions
discussions entre la direction
discussions entre les représentants du
personnel les délégués syndicaux
on rappelle qu' un accord de
compétitivité est prévue d'ici la
mi-février pour la direction et il faut
trouver un accord d'ici là c'est en tout
cas ce que souhaite la direction et se
souhaitent les syndicats
j'ai en effet c'est ce que souhaite la
direction elle mais en contrepartie
un pseudo engagements de ne pas fermer
d'usinés ou de sites industriels ce qui
de toute façon ne sera pas le cas
puisque déjà le site de rueil malmaison
dont qui étudie les moteurs sera fermée
et rassemblés sur le technocentre et la
suppression de 2000 emplois dans
l'ingénierie véhicules parmi les huit
mille deux cent soixante emplois qui
seront supprimés
avant cela ses impacts aura forcément
directement le technocentre qu'on a
aperçu sur ces images à quelques
instants du côté de de guyancourt
discussions aujourd'hui pour parvenir
ensuite un accord c'était le troisième
rendez vous depuis l'annoncé de ces
suppressions de postes qu'elles ont été
un petit peu les avancées obtenues
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il y a eu des
avancées avec ces discussions qui se
sont poursuivies
il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu
d'avancée la direction annoncé elle
qu'elle avait tout donné et qu'elle
qu'elle attendait des propositions des
syndicats et
notamment ceux de la cgt on va redonner
quelques informations pour les
téléspectateurs pour bien comprendre
cette situation 7500 et 8000 260
suppressions de postes annoncées en
france d'ici 2016 c'est 15% des
effectifs pour autant la direction
annonce que si un accord est trouvé il
n'y aura pas de fermeture de site
d'ailleurs la direction a aussi précisé
par la suite la semaine dernière que
même s'il n'y avait pas d'accord il n'y
aurait pas de fermeture et que c'était
c'est du coup cette menace chantage qui
auraient été exercées n'existait pas par
la direction pour vous vous maintenez
est-ce que du côté des syndicats on
maintient la direction fait pression qui
évoque des fermetures tout à fait la
direction fait pression pour la
signature d'un accord et sur la
fermeture des sites un des sites
industriels de toute façon avec 8 milles
environ 8000 emplois de moins
la société renault ne sera plus en
capacité de produire la demande des
clients
lorsqu'il y aura une reprise des ventes
et du marché automobile
parmi les différents sites qui
pourraient éventuellement faire mais
pourquoi pas celui de flins celle ci
fait donc département des yvelines il y
avait une forte mobilisation une fois de
plus ce matin anthony rech pour la
rédaction de tv fils y était et la
tension monte vous allez le voir
la colère monte chez les salariés
renault de flins ce mardi matin ils ont
effectué leur première opération coup de
poing aux abords du site
bloquant la circulation pendant près
d'une heure
leur message est clair ils vont se
battre contre le plan de compétitivité
annoncé par la direction qui présente
7500 élus 1260 suppressions d'emplois
dont plus de la moitié en est par nature
elle aujourd'hui c'est un avertissement
demain vous verrez on allait en est
capable on est déterminés on est capable
de se battre comme des lions pour
empêcher le chômage de ravager la vie de
millions de gens
pendant que les autres s'en mettre plein
les poches on est capable d'aller très
très très loin personnel soupçonne on
est selon les syndicats la marque au
losange aurait réalisé un profit de 786
millions d'euros sur les six premiers
mois de 2012
pour la première fois depuis l'annnonce
du plan les agents de maîtrise se
seraient joints au mouvement
cette révolte s'adresse aussi au
gouvernement on voudrait faire passer ce
message appuyé montebourg monsieur
montebourg a effectué mon avis tu
chantais à l'émission mais nouveau pour
nous montebourg ces paroles et paroles
les paroles il a des très belles paroles
mais bon il à peine 15%
enfin renault l état en 15% et on pense
que de paroles il faut qu'ils passent
aux actes
les salariés étaient près de 500 ce
matin réunis devant l'usiné renault de
flins et les syndicats donnent déjà
rendez vous mardi prochain 5 février
pour une nouvelle action ou encore
mathieu golinelli pour la cgt mais sur
le technocentre renault de guyancourt
votre avis sur la situation à flins on
voit là la pression augmente
véritablement il ya une tension très
forte du côté des salariés des syndicats
oui tout à fait dans les usines la
pression monte et
et vous pourriez imaginer la même chose
au technocentre me nous espérons la même
chose technocentre à guyancourt
mais la mobilisation des cadres et des
techniciens ne se fait pas encore sentir
malheureusement éventuellement est ce
qu'il y a aussi déjà des échanges avec
les salariés du site de flins oui il ya
des échanges avec les salariés du site
du site de flins et des autres sites
industriels et pour mener une action ont
mené une action conjointe dans les
prochains jours nous avons également en
ligne
ali kaya bonsoir délégué syndical cgt du
côté de flins on vous a vu dans le
reportage et quelques instants mobilisés
ce matin les débrayages se sont
poursuivis dans l'après midi vous avez
poursuivi cette mobilisation 1200
salariés qui sont en grève la grève qui
sera reconduite aussi dès demain vous
allez poursuivre l'action dans les
prochains jours vous parlez de monter la
mobilisation d'un cran nous avons aussi
le représentant cgt mais sur le
technocentre donc accueilli en cours est
une action conjointe pourrait être
envisagée tous les rebonds pour voir
qu'on va faire complètement parce que on
était fier et déterminé je suis pas dans
la facilité
aujourd'hui j'ai fait la réalité
derrière laquelle alors renault qui
annonce pourtant qu'il n'y aura pas de
fermeture qu'il y ait ou non d'ailleurs
un accord avant le plan de compétitivité
qui doit être présenté à la mi février
mais du côté des syndicats on l'entend
avec vous ce soir et puis avec un autre
invité sur le plateau il ya une vraie
crainte et la crainte porte sur ce site
de flins de fermeture vous craignez la
pour la fermeture de flins
mille quatre cent soixante postes mais
pas de fermeture d'une quelque chose
comment allons-nous faire fonctionner
des usines à l'autre alors
qu'aujourd'hui qui font déjà
or de faire de ce qu'il faudrait les
conditions de travail sont faibles voilà
d'accord et donc le site de flins
concrètement pourrait fermer et vous
c'est une certitude
la fidh et de ses travailleurs de
fermeture pour les chômeurs de la région
quelles sont les propositions
aujourd'hui que vous faites lors de ses
différentes réunions comment intervient
la cgt quelles sont les attentes que
vous pouvez avoir écouté bien que sacré
coeur de l'affairé ternit nos
propositions que je suis un le retrait
du projet d'accord élaboré par
l'activité sur le film bat toi tu que
par après l'emploi de tels abus donc si
ça doit coûter de l'argent et y puise
dans les prochaines qui veulent alors
enregistrés ces derniers temps que tu
dises mêmes qui vont à contre a pu le
faire vite afin de faire balle emploi
nous proposons que l'emploi soit même de
lait de coco à ali kaya une dernière
question nous parlions tout à l'heure
notamment sur ce plateau de la situation
du côté de psa peugeot-citroën ya eu un
sursis un premier sursis en tout cas
avec une décision de justice qui demande
la suspension du plan social
concrètement vous pouvez imaginer aussi
des actions avec les salariés de
peugeot-citroën olivia sur la semaine
dernière nous l'avons fait il est
absolument pas le truc que la semaine
prochaine nous faisions laudatio commune
parce que de toute façon nous comme
pétards à ouattara ado un patronat qui
n'a qu'une chose en tête
le profit malgré la crise merci ali kaya
de la cgt renault à flins merci d'avoir
été en ligne avec nous les actions qui
se sont donc poursuivies au cours de
l'après midi vous venez de l'entendre
avec des 1200 salariés c'est ce
qu'annonce hélas la cgt 1200 salariés en
grève
carlos ghosn qui annonce des ventes ul
mans renault ne serait pas à l'abri de
disparaître du moins sous sa forme
actuelle c'est une déclaration qui date
d'il ya quelques jours du pdg donc de
renault vous l'imaginez vous le concevez
ça que renault puisse disparaître
nous salariés devant que le technocentre
on n'ose pas l'imaginer mais un bon
malheureusement vous avez réagi à cette
déclaration vous avait bondi lorsque
carlos ghosn a évoqué cette situation
oui nous avons nous avons bondi et c'est
c'est un peu un désespoir qui s'est
emparée aussi des salariés au bureau
d'études nous allons juste faire une
pause avant de poursuivre la discussion
sur ce plateau nous allons nous rendre
dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines dans le rue du dr dans les rues
du département pour savoir ce que vous
évoque justement c'est possible pourquoi
pas en tout cas c'est le pdg de renault
qui l'évoquent disparition de renault on
a du mal à imaginer que renault
disparaissent mais bon ça reste possible
ouais ça reste aussi tout disparaît tout
donc pourquoi pas ça c'est pas parce que
quelque chose est là depuis des
décennies que ça ne disparaîtra pas on
n'en sait rien non parce que je viens de
lire sur
internet un article sur les quinze
prochains pays des plus riches et sur
les 15 marques de voitures les plus
faciles qui auront le plus d'importance
et la clio est en deuxième position
donc dans les dix années à venir donc ça
m'a plutôt réjouie que ça va dépendre je
pense d'eux
de ski devant décider de faire au niveau
de l'électrique notamment je crois voir
non non je pense qu'ils vont se remettre
ils recréent des nouveaux modèles et
puis aussi remettre nature y aura des
emplois perdus malheureusement mais non
je pense pas du tout que la marque
renault puisse disparaître
pas du tout mais les français qui sont
attachés à cette marque renault tout à
fait vous sentez un soutien justement
aujourd'hui par la population oui nous
sommes nous sentons un soutien de la
part de la population par rapport à la
marque renouvelle société juste pour
conclure nous aurons l'occasion dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
éditions de revenir sur cette situation
dans l'automobile un appui notamment
dans le département des des yvelines qui
est fortement fortement impacté par
cette situation est très très difficile
comment vous envisager la suite parce
que vu la situation économique actuelle
on imagine mal d'entreprises de revenir
sur ce plan sur ce plan sur ces
suppressions d'emplois il va y avoir
forcément des décisions difficiles à
prendre
il ya peut-être des décisions difficiles
à prendre mais si nous voulons préparer
l'avenir
il faut que le technocentre fils est en
mesure de concevoir le véhicule sans
sans les délocaliser ses études que ce
soit en roumanie en inde ou encore et
merci à vous d'être venu donc sur ce
plateau pour témoigner de cette
situation difficile du côté de renault
les syndicats qui sont toujours
mobilisés avec les suppressions de
postes évoquées autres entreprises mêmes
difficultés toujours dans le département
des yvelines
alcatel lucent l'équipementier télécoms
a annoncé en fin d'année dernière un
plan social qui prévoit la 1353
suppressions de postes la disparition
aussi du site de vélizy considéré comme
le siège de l'entreprise en france une
partie des salariés seulement seraient
conservés ils rejoindraient le site de
nozay dans l'essonne
on en sait un peu plus sur ces
suppressions de postes une période de
deux mois sera ouverte pour les départs
volontaires et ensuite ce sera une série
de mesures pour désigner les personnes
licenciées âge compétences seront
examinées notamment 500 salariés ont
manifesté la semaine dernière devant
l'assemblée nationale pour interpeller
elle les aide députés et puis concernant
toujours dans l'emploi le groupe vers
jean on a appris à dans l'après midi que
le pdg du label indépendant naïve
patrick zelnik
et qui se porte candidat à la reprise de
l'entreprise demandent aujourd'hui
véritablement le soutien de l'état pour
sauver non seulement l'entreprise mais
aussi le magasin des champs-elysées afin
de lui redonner une vraie vocation de
spécialistes 1200 postes sont menacés
dont la quarantaine d'emplois à saint
quentin en yvelines
en marge de ces difficultés l'entreprise
eads va elle connaître quelques
changements à sa tête la rumeur du week
end a été confirmée par le ministère de
l'économie et des finances anne
lauvergeon l'ancienne présidente du
directoire d'areva jean claude trichet
l'ancien président de la bce vont sous
réserve de l'approbation de l'assemblée
générale des actionnaires
donc rejoindre le conseil
d'administration du groupe européen
d'aéronautique eads un groupe et qui est
implanté dans le département des
yvelines à elancourt à travers sa
branche astrium dans un instant nous
allons parler d'un autre coup de sang
celui du responsable de la fédération du
bâtiment dans les yvelines la situation
sur le secteur qui s'aggrave
aucune mesure à venir pour inverser à la
tendance il nous dira ce qu'il en pense
pour le moment versailles l'a fait
montigny le bretonneux également un baby
sitting gates pour faciliter la tâche
des parents le rendez vous avait lieu ce
week end
reportage de jouer à maçonnerie et d'
anthony rech
audrey à 17 ans à la recherche de baby
sitting ponctuelle elle a participé aux
premiers baby site dating organisé par
la ville de montigny le principe
organiser des rencontres entre les
parents et les jeunes à la recherche de
garde d'enfants je suis en terminale
donc mon emploi du temps me permet pas
de pouvoir avoir du peps thing tous les
soirs la semaine donc sans l'occasionnel
quand les parents ont besoin
on se retrouve avec 47 parents inscrits
+2 qui sont venus spontanément
aujourd'hui on a plus de 50 jeunes qui
ont répondu présent on est sur une
demande de fait un peu particulière en
cette période de l'année on a
effectivement plus de parents en
recherche de baby sitter occasionnels et
on a plus de lycéens effectivement en
disponibilité c'est très bien comme ça
on reçoit tout de suite les cv on voit
la personne en plus les enfants
rencontrent la personne en direct parmi
les quatre candidats qu'elle a
rencontrés vera a réussi à trouver une
baby sitter comme elle élise une autre
maman n'est resté qu'une heure à sa
table de baby sitting
elle a néanmoins récolté une douzaine de
cv dont celui d'audrey j'ai trouvé
audrey très souriante elle a un
excellent relationnel je pense je pense
qu'elle se débrouille déjà pas mal avec
les enfants pour ce que j'ai pu en voir
je pense que je me suis assez bien vendu
qu'on profil a dû intéresser qui a vu
combien de familles j'en suis à 5
donc on verra ce que ça va donner
c'est pas mal c'est fini pour toi maman
jusqu'à 18 heures parce que je veux
continuer le plus possible voire le plus
de familles possible pour avoir
peut-être derrière le plus de rappels
possible des jeunes motivés qui consacre
un après midi entier à la recherche
d'enfants à garder la concurrence
s'annonce difficile mais audrey possède
une arme secrète
je suis très forte en scoubidou